[Music]
we are in the call 8 phone bank awaiting
your calls to answer your questions
about medicare enrollment the annual
enrollment period is going on right now
until december 7th and this is the time
to call as we go on throughout the
evening
these phones get really busy so this is
the opportunity 702-650-1101
your questions about medicare whatever
they may be it can be a complicated
process and that's we are why we are
joined by jennifer from select health
thanks for being here thank you so much
for having us so this is the the right
time to be enrolling there are lots of
things to consider when enrolling in
medicare what are some of those there
are a lot of things to look over i mean
a lot can happen in a year right so you
might want to review your plan make sure
your provider is still in network
go through your prescriptions make sure
those are still covered at the level
that you would like them to be because
different plans have different options
so it's always good to do an annual
review just like you would
on anything else just to kind of make
sure it's still meeting your needs
and a lot of plans have come out with
some really great stuff this year and
there's a lot of really great perks and
benefits and incentives for wellness
activities so you might want to take
advantage of those
and just kind of review all the options
that are out there yeah and there is a
window now that goes until december 7th
when people can enroll so this would be
not only for first-time enrollees but as
you were alluding to people who may
already be enrolled in medicare but
maybe it's time to adjust the plan how
do people know if they should adjust
their medicare plan well
conveniently we have our select health
answer team to help you go through your
coverages and kind of see what's working
for you and what might not be working
for you and can also
bring to your attention some other
options that are out there jennifer
vogel thanks so much for being here
phone lines are open and they will be
until seven o'clock tonight but again
jump on it right now as they and during
commercial breaks once we go to
commercial it slows down a little bit
seven zero two six five zero eleven
we will be right back